انتقادات لاذعه بين الجمهوريين في سباق
الرئاسه الامريكي هذه المره مصدرها ليست
ترامب نيكي هيلي المرشحه الجمهوريه تطلق
الاتهامات بحق منافسيها الجمهوريين الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب وحاكم فلوريدا
رونديسانس قائله انهما ليس صادقين مع
الشعب هيلي اعتبرت ان كل من ترامب وديسانس
قال انهما لن يتعامل مع اصلاح الاستحقاقات
لكن كل ما يفعلانه هو ترك الامر للرئيس
المقبل الامر الذي يجعل الكثير من
الامريكيين في مازق على حد قولها
على العكس ترامب بدا يغير من سياسته
واسلوبه الهجومي بعض الشيء وغدا يركز على
الافكار بدلا من الحرب الكلاميه على خصومه
فقد تحدث عن افكاره تجاه ملفات عده بينها
الاستقلال في مجال الطاقه والتغيير
المطلوب في برامج التعليم
وحذر الجمهوريين من تجنب اجراء اي تغييرات
فوريه على برامج الرعايه الطبيه او الضمان
الاجتماعي على الرغم من ان ادارته كانت
تخطط بالفعل لخفض مزايا قسائم الطعام قبل
ان يمنع القاضي هذه الخطوه في اكتوبر 2020
اما حاكم فلوريدا روندسانس فنعت ترامب
مؤخرا بالمحتال اكثر من مره ووصفه بانه
يسير على نهج عنوانه ان قياده معسكر
الجمهوريين تتطلب قدرا من التنمر والهجوم
السياسيه كانت ترامب دعم ترشح اديسانس
كحاكم لولايه فلوريدا لكن سرعان ما تغيرت
العلاقه بين الرجلين
ويعول الديسانس على ان يظهر بصوره مختلفه
امام الناخبين وهي انه الحرس الجديد لحزب
الجمهوريين بمواجهه ترامب
قات المزيد
من الاخت على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات